colorado state representative tom
sullivan ran for office after his son
was killed in the mass shooting at a
movie theater in aurora colorado
27-year-old alex sullivan was one of 12
people who died that day
in 2012. state representative tom
sullivan joins us now
representative sullivan thank you so
much for joining us i'm telling you
it is the stories that get to me and i
remember reading about your son i
remember hearing about his story
these people went to the grocery store
your son went to the movie theater
nothing
nothing can prepare you for the these
kind of moments
so can you help us understand what the
families are going through now
you've been there absolutely i mean to
hear that i mean there
she said it was 12 hours before they got
um the notification and and that was
um you know what it took for us you know
our shooting happened at 12 38 in the
morning we didn't get notification until
8 10 p.m um so you know that was my
concern you know
how how are they going to be they talked
about the room you know we sat in the
exact same room with
all of the families you know in
different you know sections
um getting briefings trying to keep it
together
um you know it's yeah it's it's just
yeah it's just it's helpful it's awful
tom what helped you most and
and what is your message for the
families now who are in so much pain
well one of the things that i i try to
remember
to to let them know is is that like you
know right now you need
the people that you trust the people
that you love that's who needs to be
around you
um that's who you need to reach out to
there are good intention
people around but you know when the
cameras leave and the lights are dimmed
again
it's just going to be you and them again
and and that's who um
needs to um remember and and quite
frankly i mean to tell you
it takes a special friend to to walk
into that room that you're setting in
with you know
nine other families waiting for that
word and and you you will
you will truly know who you can count on
someone who would walk into that room
who has no reason
to be in there other than their love for
you
hey representative sullivan i'd like to
talk a bit about
the possible legislative response to
this mayor weaver there of boulder
told us earlier he thought a national
assault weapons ban
would have helped i presume you agree
but when you talk to republican
lawmakers
in your state there in colorado what
kind of response do you get when you
bring up what some consider common sense
gun control legislation
well they're they're they're spreading
fear this this is their their
their thing is to spread fear they they
had record-setting
uh number of firearm transfers here in
the state of colorado
um last year we had over 500 000
of them um you know transfer um
yesterday we had
a uh hearing on uh reporting of lost and
stolen firearms
of which 60 of them already do it
and when we brought that up their first
thing was to say this was
the beginning of registration um they
were comparing us to nazis
for doing something like this and quite
frankly 60 of them
are doing it already and no one's
confiscating their firearms
no one's coming and getting them but
that's what they tell people
and and the you know the floodgates are
opening once again
to go and buy more firearms because
someone is coming to get you well that
is an unfortunate echo
in the aftermath of events like this
there is a tragedy there's a
conversation about
reform efforts and then there is a rush
to go out and buy more firearms
we heard an argument from senator ted
cruz yesterday
that these proposed changes to gun
legislation
wouldn't in fact stop tragedies like the
one we saw on monday
what's your response to that all of
these
collectively all of these types of
things what they do is they save lives
and that's what i'm in the business of
from from the day my son was murdered
to the day i'm not here any longer i'm
doing everything i can
to save lives yeah and it's not there's
no perfect
answer there's no there's no you know
pill that's going to stop this
there's not one law that will stop this
but each
one will help us save lives and i want
to end talking about your son
tom because you couldn't have known on
that day whenever it was that that might
have been your last conversation with
him
how do you keep him close
well i i have his jacket um that i wear
every day when i go down to the state
capitol on
on the real tough days i i wear it um
you know on the floor with me
you know i can see his eyes i can see
that smile yeah
um i i would just tell those people you
know hang on
um to the voice if you've got any um you
know text messages you've got any um
phone messages they left because that's
the first thing you lose
it's it's difficult to try to re you
know hear him anymore
um so um you know and it's the work yes
hang on to the voices steve hartman is a
correspondent here who does one of the
best human interest stories
i think ever and one thing he said after
the las vegas shooting i think he said
we know this song so what do we do we
mourn pray
repeat we mourn pray repeat and i just
look forward to the day where we don't
have to play that song anymore
thank you so much for the work you're
doing thank you
thank you tom sullivan